now what is what is Dr Burke talking
about now eggs and butter actually
helping your cholesterol profile how can
that be now of course if you have
familial hypercholesterol anemia which
is a genetic problem this does not apply
to that sector of the population also if
you are what's called a hyper responder
this information doesn't apply but for
everyone else I think it does apply and
just hear me out so let's first talk
about the egg yolk the egg yolk has one
of the highest sources of cholesterol
mobilizing nutrients number one choline
okay and number two lecithin both of
these compounds help you mobilize
cholesterol out of the body and the
thing you need to know about eggs for
example is that one egg gives you
roughly about 186 milligrams of
cholesterol but you have to also realize
that your body makes cholesterol it
makes a lot it makes like 3 000
milligrams of cholesterol every single
day so if we look at 3 000 milligrams
and 186 milligrams there's a big
difference between those two and in that
egg yolk Mother Nature has provided the
mobilizers of cholesterol and I'm going
to put a lot of data Down Below in
studies but dietary cholesterol which
means the amount of cholesterol you're
eating is not associated with increasing
your cholesterol and that's kind of a
counterintuitive but that's just a fact
also there is no study that shows that
consuming eggs negatively affect your
cardiovascular system yet in one study
which is a pretty interesting study it
was talking about the two phytonutrients
in egg yolks lutein and zeaxanthin which
happen to improve the cholesterol
profile in the carbohydrate restrictive
group so they looked at people on a low
carb diet and how their cholesterol was
altered when eating eggs they showed a
lower oxidative cholesterol reading they
also showed higher levels of the type of
LDL that doesn't create a problem in
your arteries and this is basically
differentiating the two types of LDL and
the particle size okay so you have the
large buoyant LDL and you also have the
small dense LDL in the group that
restricted their carbohydrates there is
a much better LDL profile that supports
healthy arteries and the other thing
that I found interesting about the study
they talked about lutein and zeaxanthin
those two phytonutrients are better
absorbed in eggs than they are in plants
which made me wonder about what about
all the phytonutrients in beef would
that be better absorbed well apparently
there's not any studies done on that and
I'll have to possibly do that study
later on sometime but the point is that
animals you know eat plants and they get
these phytonutrients and if we eat the
animals we indirectly get the benefits
of some of these phytonutrients and the
added benefit of just better absorption
as well the other interesting thing
about egg yolks is that they're a good
source of vitamin K2 which protects the
heart it keeps the calcium for building
up in the arteries okay it drives the
calcium into the bone so as far as a
food that supports your heart and your
cholesterol eggs are right at the top of
the list now let's talk about butter
okay now I'm talking about butter from
cows that are grass-fed grass finished
not the typical grain-fed cow milk but
the grass-fed which is a whole different
thing and if you can actually
find butter that's cultured that would
be even better because now we're getting
a product with an added benefit of good
bacteria first of all butter and these
microbes greatly have an influence over
your cholesterol your own microbes make
bile salts which help to mobilize
cholesterol bile salts are involved in
the primary regulation of cholesterol
from the liver and your microbiome make
this secondary type of bile but anytime
you consume probiotics or foods with
microbes like the cultured butter
chances are you're going to help your
cholesterol profiles but I just could
not find any studies on cultured butter
and cholesterol but I do know the
importance of consuming foods that are
fermented or enriched with microbes
butter also is a good source of vitamin
K2 which is great for the heart if it's
grass-fed vitamin K2 was called The X
Factor inductor Price's evaluation on
traditional foods and fermented foods
butter is also great for anyone going
through menopause because it contains
cholesterol that can really Supply the
raw material for making sex hormones and
I'm not just talking about estrogen and
progesterone I'm also talking about
other hormones like progesterone as well
as cortisol about key hormone that helps
you with stress if someone going through
menopause is trying to go on a low-fat
diet they're going to have a hard time
with these hormones and so just to
remind you for the hundredth time
cholesterol is needed to make these
hormones
cholesterol is needed to make vitamin D
cholesterol is needed to support all the
cell membranes cholesterol is needed for
your brain and cholesterol helps your
immune system cholesterol is needed to
make bile salts which is very very
important and so this is why your liver
makes so much cholesterol it's needed
I'm going to list down below a study
that was done it was a randomized
control study that showed that butter
actually increased your LDL and another
study that shows there is a neutral
effect or association between butter
cardiovascular disease and butter and
diabetes I'll also include a link Down
Below on the relationship between
beta-carotene and lowering your
cholesterol and if you're consuming
butter from grass-fed cows you're
getting a lot of beta-carotene and you
would see the color of butter being more
yellow than white if it was loaded with
beta-carotene but butter also has
several other things that are very very
beneficial official for your cholesterol
profile one is called CLA and CLA has
been known to decrease cholesterol
decrease inflammation help you lose
weight and it stands for conjugated
linoleic acid the word conjugated just
basically means combined with a protein
and then butter also has butyric acid or
butyrate and this is a small chain fatty
acid that also has the potential to
lower cholesterol and it's used to help
fuel the colon cells so it's great to
decrease inflammation in your colon It's
also been known to support leaky gut and
it helps to prevent the absorption of
cholesterol in your intestines which is
interesting grass-fed butter also
contains omega-3 fatty acids that can
also have an effect on cholesterol and
there's some great research on ghee
which is clarified butter they're
removing the solids out of the milk and
having just the pure butter fat and its
effect on lowering cholesterol which is
also very interesting exercise can also
help you lower cholesterol and if you're
concerned about your cholesterol and you
have high cholesterol and you want some
additional things to do I'm just going
to Rattle off a few things that you can
start taking niacin can significantly
lower cholesterol NATO kinase is another
remedy that can help lower cholesterol
red yeast extract is another remedy
which can mimic sentence and my favorite
bile salts because bile salts can help
regulate the mobilization of cholesterol
from your liver so in summary I would
not be worried about consuming eggs and
butter if you have problems with
cholesterol or if you're concerned about
your heart just make sure that you have
quality eggs okay and you have quality
butter now since we're on this topic if
you have not seen this video on eggs
which got a lot of views I think you
want to check it out I put up right here